Barry Allen they call him the fastest
man alive he's not the worst rations
so much one seemed to be bad it's pretty
messed up this is ground zero for pretty
messed up
hey youtubers it's Charlie huge night 1
million subscribers and we have new
flash footage of killer frost and the
reverse-flash that's right yo barth on
is coming back so you know big break
down let's do it I guess it's no
coincidence that like my x 1 million
subscriber video also it's like a
reverse flash ring giveaway so new round
of the rivers flash ring giveaway
audience do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video so
starting with the reverse-flash he's
coming back in episode 11 he basically
threatens one of the members of STAR
Labs they didn't say which member but in
the trailer we hear like creepy Harrison
wells from earth-2 voice saying that the
flash is the fastest man alive but
that's not true because it's the reverse
flash technically the reverse flash is
still a little bit faster and when we're
talking about the reverse-flash coming
back we're talking about the mat lecture
reverse flash the one that we saw in
episode 17 you know who is a Ubar
thought that was actually the name of
that episode where it showed a barth on
showing up getting stranded during the
20th century in having to like suck up
the DNA of harrison wells to pretend to
be him so that he could create the flash
and try to get back to the future it's
all very cat's in the cradle but the
reverse-flash that's coming back will be
that a bar thought the true evil bars on
reverse flash not from Earth to the guy
from Earth one the really big question I
know you're all asking is is like how
does you bought dawn still exist if
Eddie killed himself well Eddie kind of
got pulled into that time paradox vortex
so I'm assuming that there'll be some
sort of timing why me explanation
because until we hear otherwise I'm
going to assume this is Earth one ear
bar thought they actually didn't specify
that when they made the announcement
they just said abarth on so I think
that's going to be our earth one version
if you really want to get technical
about it Eddie Thawne killing himself
would have erased a bar dawn from
existence which means that the Future II
abarth on would have never come back to
try and kill Barry the first time
completely resetting everything so since
that didn't happen we can assume there's
also an explanation as to why future ear
bought on still exists but the really
cool thing about the character is that
he started out with Tom Cavanagh like
Tom Cavanagh created that whole
character and then Matt let's sure had
to come along and play like a different
version of the character so like we have
Harrison wells but then we learned that
he is secretly someone else so it's a 0
bars on pretending to be Harrison wells
it's Tom Cavanagh pretending to be ill
Barth on pretending to be
harrison wells then we get 2 episode 17
last year and we get to meet your bar
dawn before he became the Harrison wells
eobard thawne so what they said is is
around the mid-season finale is about
about the time that they cast the
character and he had to go to Tom
Cavanagh and they kind of had to work
out the character together like ok so
I've seen what you've done with this guy
so I'm gonna be playing like a proto
version of that before he starts acting
like your guy is completely fascinating
it was this amazing collaboration
between those two actors between top
cabin on Matt ledger so I'm guessing an
episode 11 when we see him he is still
going to be passionate with hate for
Barry if you remember the message that
Barry watched at the beginning of season
two like that the reverse flash was
telling him you're never going to be
happy you won but you're never going to
be happy the eobard thawne that we meet
in episode 11 won't be that far along
like his character won't have gotten to
that point he'll probably still hate the
out of Barry but back to that
creepy Harrison wells voiceover it's not
true that the flash is the fastest man
alive here's my big question for you
guys do you think that Harrison wells of
birth to is gonna try and throw the
reverse-flash under the bus for zoom be
like look zoom this guy's way faster
steal his speed not berries that was
actually the reason why I thought that
we weren't going to see the
reverse-flash you know right right away
because it's like if he shows up zoom is
going to see this giant battery of Speed
Force and just be like I'm gonna take
all this but we do see zoom in the
trailer oinking patty so obviously we're
gonna have to deal with him pretty soon
too I don't know which episode that
happens and but I think it happens
before Barry tells her a secret and then
and then we have to talk about killer
frost this is going to be sasa it's so
much more fun to be bad and even iris of
earth to looks like she's kind of bad
she just kind of looks like she has a
chillier personality and Barry looks
like this totally normal guy that just
can't handle it really the WTF in that
moment is the iris character because
she's like the most loving warm
character on the show and caitlin snow
too i'm wondering what's going to go on
with Jay Garrick because jay garrick's
from earth-2 but he hasn't said anything
about the earth to version of the
characters that we know like why hasn't
he said anything about killer frost
mirth to why hasn't he said anything
about earth to bury my thought is is
that the writers just don't want to
reveal that yet like they were just kind
of writing those characters out trying
to figure out what they wanted those
personas to be like but danielle
panabaker said that she is so excited to
be killer frost she was like we worked
so hard on that outfit from season one I
had no idea when I was going to get to
weird again but then come to find out
we're gonna see her on earth too that's
the easy way to do killer frost without
completely throwing earth 1 Caitlyn
under the bus like kill killer frost in
order for her to be evil she wouldn't be
able to be friends with Barry anymore so
earth to is just like the workaround to
get there faster so happy everything is
possible at earth to I think I actually
said that in another video there isn't a
whole lot of Wally West in the trailer
but there is that funny line worries
like wow that's messed up and Jose like
yeah we're crying at ground zero for
messed up now that he's here I'm just
expecting to get like Joe Wally moments
at least once in episode so I'm hoping
he's in every single episode the back
half of the season but you know it might
not be every single episode don't know
anything about him becoming Kid Flash he
doesn't look that much younger than
Grant Gustin but they basically pitching
him as the Kid Flash version of the
flash like he's not gonna also be called
the flash when he gets his powers so
freaking excited and so happy that this
is happening when I'm hitting a million
subscribers seriously I had no idea that
this would ever happen you guys are all
amazing I can't wait for everything to
come back there's actually going to be
some Deadpool later this week so nice
early Christmas chimichangas for
everyone white guys wait for everything
to post I totally just did a new
Deadpool video you can click here to
watch that and you can click here for
all my episode 7 videos you guys are so
awesome let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight